[Music]
all about acknowledging your
shortcomings in life a lot of people
talk about triple down on your strengths
triple down on your strengths and don't
worry about your shortcomings that's a
whole new thing I'm hearing right now
maybe it's not new best new to me
because I'm not out there really
listening to all this stuff that's the
quickest way to never grow to never grow
if you sit there and have that mentality
of triple down on what you're good at
you're never going to grow you're always
going to stay the same either you're
getting better you're getting worse so
one thing that helped me out a lot when
I was growing up was people always asked
me how do you build mental toughness
mental toughness well I had these
classes out here a class on mental
toughness positive thinking
visualization all these different
techniques mental toughness is a
lifestyle it's something that you live
every single day of your life when I was
growing up I was a lazy kid I was a lazy
kid never goes how did you get to where
you're at today how did you get to where
you running 200 miles at one time in 39
hours being so disciplined
it started off honestly with recognizing
that my bedroom was dirty my bed wasn't
made I lived a sloppy life so I took
very small increments in my life I
started making my bath started cleaning
my room there were dishes in the sink it
started off with doing small house
chores I saw that the yard needs to be
mowed so instead of being told you need
to be mowed I would mow it I started
doing things coming outside of my lazy
ways to become better and through a
period of time your brain doesn't like
it but it starts to realize this is a
new way of thinking we are now doing
things that we aren't comfortable doing
we are doing things that we don't want
to do so the brain starts to slowly grow
and let's say you don't like to get up
early in the morning time to go run I
hated it I still hate it you do that
you live uncomfortable to gain growth
you have to have friction in your life
to gain growth and the only way to do
that is to make yourself uncomfortable
and get to the point where instead of
running from the things you don't want
to do you actually face them and start
to gain more and more growth in your
life so that's how I approach all those
things self-talk for me has been the
biggest thing in my life a lot of us
have a dialogue that is crap it's a
crappy dialogue we live in a world right
now that is very external everything is
very on the surface superficial
everything and what we're telling
ourselves is what we see on TV is what
we see on instagrams we see on Facebook
and we're telling ourselves stuff that
doesn't really penetrate to our core to
the inside of our soul so our self-talk
is like what am I gonna wear today how
am I gonna look today I need to act this
way today because this way is cool
my self-talk became something that
actually made me better and I had a
whole bunch of negative things in my
life and to get to the self-talk portion
of it first you have to quiet all of the
phones and social media and all the
negativity of the world to get to even
hear your own self have a self talk you
can't have self talk if you're hearing
someone else's dialogue and what they're
putting out on social media how they
want you to act how they want you to
dress how they want you to talk
everything out there is you're trying to
keep up with somebody you're not trying
to find your own self
so you have to clear away all the crap
and how you clear where the crap to even
get to your self-talk is you have to get
all of the noise of all the crap of the
world out of your head so I call it
going to a dark place you have to get
the noise out quiet your mind down get
all the static out before you can even
have a real conversation with yourself
and the in that self-talk a lot of times
it's very negative because of all the
stuff we see on TV all the stuff we see
social media you have to create a
positive dialogue there's something I do
that I have a demonstration and I make
somebody very strong and I can make him
very weak within three seconds
I put self-talk I put my own voice in
their subconscious and I do something to
them that makes them very weak and they
wonder how in the world do you do this I
do it because I'm putting my own
dialogue in your head I'm telling a
person that you're insecure I'm telling
a person that's you're weak and I'm able
to make this person almost they have no
strength and then I give it right back
to them it all day long we are feeding
ourselves the wrong self-talk it's
negative self-talk so all day long
I'm putting the positive self-talk in my
subconscious I'm making sure that I'm
walking around all day long giving
myself to proper fuel to attack the
world that's why I work out hard every
day I work out hard every day because I
know the first thing in the morning what
I do is I clean my room I clean my house
I go for a run I work out I want to win
the war in the morning because a second
I leave my house
the second you look at your phone the
second you turn the TV on you're in a
battle all this negativity is coming at
you but if you're able to fuel yourself
in the morning win the war in the
morning so you have the strength to face
what you're going to face in the world
the world's going to come at you with
left's and rights you have to have the
right kind of mentality and that starts
by not hitting the snooze button it
starts by waking up no you don't want to
do it but that gives you the strength
because you did it if you do it if you
do something you don't want to do every
morning you're already giving yourself
to proper self-talk you're already
giving yourself to proper dialogue to
attack that people that don't like you
to attack your insecurities to attack
what the world's going to give you so
self-talk comes from belief in yourself
if you give me
self-talk positive self-talk but you
don't believe it it's not going to come
true you have to put the work behind
what you're saying and believe what
you're saying yourself for that
self-talk to become a reality in your
subconscious so no matter what anybody
says to you and what you hear you know
the truth and you're living through the
truth and no one can
no one can penetrate that no one so one
thing I developed in my life going
through hard times is a cookie jar the
cookie jar is all of us have a story
we've all overcome so many things in our
lives but we forget them and in a lot of
times we don't spend enough time like
reflecting back in our lives realizing
how great we truly are we go through
something we put it back and we go on in
life is going to always challenge us
always challenge us and during that
challenge the moment we panic we forget
who we truly are that cookie jar that I
designed for my brain is something that
in that one second of panic we lose our
mind and we also lose how far we've come
in life you take that one second go
through your cookie jar grab something
in your mind look at it read it open it
up
oh I was in three hell weeks I graduated
two of them that's a cookie it reminds
yourself just how hard you are and it
puts you right back into the right frame
of mind to overcome whatever's in front
of you and usually whatever's in front
of you isn't as big as you make it out
to be we start to make these very small
things enormous because we allow our
minds to take control and go away from
us
we have to regain control of our mind
and that's what the cookie jar is it's
getting wreak it's gaining control of a
situation that isn't that big most
situations in life aren't that big and
if they are that big usually we can find
the strength to handle them just through
having the right mental process the 40
percent rule something I designed all
surrounds growing up I realized when our
300 pounds and I lost all the weight to
become a Navy SEAL I realized that I
could have lived the rest of my life
being a 300 pound person never knowing
what was truly inside of me I couldn't
have been happy with that person I was
living at about 40% maybe not even 40%
so in life like a car a car a lot of
cars have governors on them a governor
is something where let's say the
speedometer says I hunt 30 miles an hour
you put a governor on a car it may only
go 91 miles an hour because that
governor stops that car from going 130
we do the same thing to our brain when
our brain starts to go through suffering
when our brain starts to go through pain
or starts to go through insecurities
when we start to feel uncomfortable with
ourself our brain gives us a way out and
that way out is usually quitting or
taking the easier route if we're able to
look at ourselves and face whatever
we're running from you start to gain
more percent on top of that 40 you start
to realize okay you start to slowly take
that governor off your brain we can do a
lot more than we think like at work a
lot of us have a horrible mentality at
work we go to work we put all these
negative things in our brains and it
starts to cap our potential we cap our
potential by saying we're giving 100% no
one's really given a hundred percent
usually you're given 40 percent because
that governor stopping you you feel pain
you feel suffering you feel discomfort
you stop right there everybody has a
wall in their mind it's a wall and it
stops us from going further most walls
have a door or a window you have to find
that you have to have the courage to
find that and once you open that door or
that window you realize how much further
you can go and you're going to continue
hitting doors in windows along this
journey but you have to have the courage
to open them up to get to that hundred
percent so it's all about having the
courage
realizing that we have a governor we
have to push past that governor in pass
their own mind games
[Music]